hey guys welcome to part two of our one
division finale reaction
breakdown theories you know all that
mumbo jumbo had a lot to say if you guys
can catch part one make sure to catch it
at least the intro i said some sweet
things also i just want to say
if elizabeth olsen paul benny and
catherine hahn are not considered
during awards season i'm gonna be pissed
anywho enjoy this reaction
the ship of theseus is an artifact in
the museum
when no original plank remains is it
still the ship of theseus
if a tree falls down in the woods and no
one's around to hear it
those remote planks are restored and
reassembled free of the rod
is that the ship of theseus both
are the true shiv oh oh dude
but i do not have the mind stone
and i did not have one single ounce of
original material
what's about to happen i think they're
about to synthesize
i have not retained memories but you do
have the data
it is merely being kept from you
free your mind a weapon to be more
easily controlled
using it against you certainly you are
the true vision for you believe yourself
to be
may
vision persuasion
vision connection oh
damn it's coming back
[Music]
uh the traumatic memories are coming
back to you
oh
but i still like the other vision kind
of more
that's a lot a lot more she's doing it
again
oh you see the difference between you
and me
i make this look good
don't mess with the scarlet witch agatha
unless she's mocking she is
[Music]
the hell are they doing they're gonna
put her on the stake
they're gonna burn the witch
[Music]
give me your power and i will correct
the flaws in your original spell you
killed
sparky agatha yeah
[Music]
come on it's one effort give us one
afterwards
there's so much action i see what paul
bettany meant about the cgi
yeah oh it's like raining fire and
brimstone now
oh god
i want it all oh god
oh no
no you're let's see why
it's too much power this world you made
will always be broken just like
you
[Music]
dr strange or she can't handle the power
yeah maybe it's not meant for her or
i'll just wait for the show to tell me
gotta get there first gotta get there
first
oh
wow dude only the witch
who cast them can you swim she's
learning fast
yeah thanks for the lesson that was like
an hour ago
it's happening
oh this is this is great this is great
yes
oh buddy
you knew this was coming pete
[Laughter]
get your scarlet witch costume when you
fix this damn spell
ah she looks great
damn we got ourselves a scarlet witch
you have no idea what you've unleashed
you're gonna need me i know where to
find you wait wait wait wait
wait
i'll be seeing your agnes not if i see
you first time
[Laughter]
all these freaking sorcerers
[Music]
the vision and the scarlet witch
oh very proud of you both
very proud a family is
forever
we could never truly leave each other
even if we tried
thanks for choosing me to be your mom
i read somewhere that's it's bad luck to
say
goodbye in the dark no you didn't
i just wanted to see you clearly
oh
you vision
are the piece of the mindstorm that
lives in me
it's literally a part of her you are a
body
of wires and blood and alone
that i created you are her vision
a body but not human and now
a memory made real
well um
god damn it
but white vision is back right
just have the hex only around this one
house
god oh
oh tommy and billy you don't hate me
giving your power i'd bring my mom back
i know i would i don't understand this
power
but i will
look at that she's like get the hell out
of here
oh my god yes it's just like wonder if
she goes into that happened
[Laughter]
please stand by definitely absolutely
not they will surprise
us anything now they're asking for you
in the theater
oh yeah who's they
i was sent by an old friend of your
mother's
[Music]
s oh yeah what are you doing up on that
space station man
the fact that the credits are still
playing and hasn't done
watch this next [ __ ] on disney places
with other programming now forget
the mood of what you just finished in
the afterglow of dallas let's get you
watching some more stuff on this
algorithm here we need people in the
system
i'm saying there's got to be something
else right exactly
i hope every theory video still comes
out with but if you pay close attention
this guy might still be mephisto this is
probably nightmare
and uh you know here's the daddy might
actually still be a witch
speaking just like agatha did a few
episodes ago it's all part of a bigger
conspiracy
so agatha's still just gonna be in west
view as the neighbor
who's just helping out the people i was
like that was one thing i did start
even without like without the hex just
yeah is she just wanda's
personal prisoner mind slave
yeah i think she's just staying in
westfield so she just lives there
bound to a house with a spell on her i
don't know you guys correct us
although i could definitely see that
opening the door in the future for some
kind of begrudging like
okay i'll i'll teach you her and mordo
team up
that'd be cool championing for more
i want more though let's do it man mordo
needs his day he was
he was talking a big game at the end of
doctor strange i know
let's see it man too much sorcerers
no more sorcerer what the hell's
happening here all right all right here
we go
there's still music something disney
come on marvel yes yeah
oh it's beautiful
soaring over california
oh
she does so damn that's uh that's
that's that's a bad situation it's a
spicy meatball right there
oh chance in hell there's a chance in
hell
hey should
all right guys this is the time of the
video where greg and john spent about 45
minutes combing through the footage
making notes doing our absolute best and
then
you guys will go down there and correct
us and that's what will be all your
feedback primarily
is that that's the important stuff go
for it or leave your theories anything
all the theories that we could think of
that were debunked that's a lot of them
my name is sarah uh dottie is not the
third witch
maybe she is maybe she could have been
putting on a ruse just like that it's
like agatha did
hold out hopefully they could all have
been they're all still
mutants maybe this links to because
eventually gets mutants in there
somewhere i thought they were going to
give birth to mutants and to kind of do
the fliparoo as opposed to no more
mutants
that didn't happen quicksilver oh boy
that's the one i know
people will have feelings about just
about that one there will be some people
who are
very upset about the handling of that
mephisto no mephisto here
although the post credit scene could be
him
maybe still could still open up the door
for some mephisti action that's
something about a lot of these is like
not all these theories are just flat out
debunked they just didn't happen yet
yes exactly oh yeah doctor strangeness
show up you know she's gonna be
going toe to toe in some way
supreme you're more powerful than that
ultron wasn't here
uh dick van dyke wasn't here neither
magneto or
or my professor x that was wrong about
that i was
percent confident one wolverine some
people were guessing topping mcguire
you know why is this paul bettany said
some [ __ ] about it
luke skywalker okay i can't i got a
cameo that's just so crazy
that is the price hasn't gotten leaked
from clearly he was talking i was like i
thought that was just a joke oh damn he
really was just talking about himself
wasn't it
he you know he said something about when
you make a joke and you didn't realize
it was going to go too far and today i
realized
that's a good assessment that british
try with i feel like he had a talking to
from the director you created the thing
and i don't know if you meant to do that
kind of the tone that seems struck by
that recent interview that came out with
the director being like look some people
are going to be disappointed i've seen
all these theories going out paul benny
dug his own grave with this one
you know or doug is on hold with this
one i have a feeling that there is some
behind the scenes talking i'm like why'd
you say that man
you know people are gonna run with that
for days
and now there's gonna be so much hype
yeah uh i was wrong
and uh he also said that the the finale
would have a
a battle where there's more cgi than
that of end game
now i don't know the technicalities of
what all involves the creation of stuff
but this didn't strike me as something
that had as much cgi it's not really a
theory that's just something that is
that
true and we don't know really who the
witness
is that jimmy set up i mean is it is it
ralph
i'm not sure what did he do to get into
witness protection the aerospace
engineer
there's a lot of hype around that like
obviously reed richards but there was
there's a thing that was being theorized
i think it's still at reed richards
easter egg like they say that rover he
sent overs like from space missions and
stuff
it's got to still be a tease it could be
anyway there's a lot more that was the
bump but those are the main ones that
came to mind things that we were hoping
to get clarity on right
and we did we got clarity on all of it
so where to start i honestly thought
like this was a very powerful episode i
loved it
i do have some qualms with it in certain
areas that i will get into
one very specific one that i think you
guys can already tell what i'm probably
hinting at
we'll go away for that you know
obviously like we've seen our reactions
were usually like goofing around a lot
more and this was one
i like really took serious i just have a
hard time saying goodbye
and i should do it with friends
it's pretty bad i just that's my defense
mechanism
i'm trying to say yeah you share on such
a broad level with people yeah
yeah it's hard to say goodbye that's
what was getting all sentimental when we
did the intro and the
in the beginning of this it's okay they
gave us two post-credits scenes just to
stretch
that out you know it gave me what i
wanted in the sense of like yeah it
gives me a cliffhanger for of what it's
setting up but it feels like the story
here is concluded
which is a lot like what he said in that
interview the director you know i felt
that was kind of a good assessment is
yeah i mean you do get a couple payoffs
but mostly it's the story
wrapping itself up and coming to a
conclusion and then yeah teasing in a
couple things but that's not the point
yeah well like wanda's going through
grief this whole thing they've become
more direct about it in the last couple
of episodes
a lot of themes out loud yeah they
become really direct about it a
therapist
once told me um that you're never going
to heal greg
give up no that's not the therapist the
therapist is
you can keep coming here i like the
money
just give me your power i'll fix this no
a therapist once told me you know
because i i've become very
i have to experience seeing quite a bit
of loss in my own personal life i became
pretty fascinated with grief and how to
grieve and like what it really means and
one thing i always tell people when
they're going through grief is like feel
your feelings feel what you got to feel
do your best not to judge yourself
and just know that whatever you're
feeling eventually leads you to the path
of acceptance basically you have the
stages of grief
some say they're five there's another
one that's like seven i usually go off
to five
one thing this therapist told me was
that every stage of grief like be doing
like denial blame
anger bargaining depression in some ways
it's all still
forms of the first stage of grief until
you're at acceptance
and then here that's kind of what you're
watching her go through in this and then
the hexagon
the walls she's created around her is
all like metaphorical for
the grief and breaking down the walls to
get to a point of accepting the reality
of the situation as she does here
with letting go of vision her family
this world of west view and seeing how
being this way especially someone her
power can harm other people like there's
that line
i think one of the it's one of the
agatha says it or one of the people
in west view says it like your grief is
poisoning us
and um that that can happen a lot of
times a lot of times the people aren't
dealing with their pain within they can
act out in ways that are harmful to
others and that they don't necessarily
recognize coming from themselves
yeah so i thought that was fascinating
how wanda has that line
to agatha when she does a cool little
age of ultron moment
and she says to her you do your thing on
purpose
i i do i don't do my thing on purpose i
don't know the exact quote but you know
what i'm saying i'm like well
still messed up what you did yeah this
is still a kind of nightmare
and when everybody wakes up at a certain
point you very much
drive that home like for whatever you
know culpability you maybe don't have
because you didn't do this out of a pure
motivation to wreck people's lives you
still wrecking people's
lives so my point being with that though
is at the end of the day she still gets
to a point of acceptance to the reality
and saying goodbye
letting go it's a really heartbreaking
scene a beautifully written scene
her saying goodbye to the children i
love how she
has those lines in there when she's
saying goodbye to tommy and billy both
her and vision saying how like a family
is forever and we can never truly leave
each other even if we tried
and which i feel like i was like oh i
was excited to be so literal by the time
we got to the post
which we'll get to you know saying thank
you for choosing me to be your mom i i i
it wasn't like an actual goodbye the way
how it was with vision again
yeah it really felt like it was even
though in the moment
it's sort of a beautiful lie there is
that sort of i bought this energy from
her yeah i'm gonna see you guys again
man how many times you have to say
goodbye to vision but i love how this
vision even had an arc himself he was
someone who was looking for the truth
and
a sense of identity of who he is and all
those lines started off with like the
piece of the mind stone that
that lives in me of what wanda saying
the sadness the love
all these qualities everything that
vision meant
to her her memories and how he's saying
like i was a voice without a body a
memory that became
real and he starts to cry it was really
heartbreaking
and i was just like shutting off
too much i can't feel this i don't know
i don't know what my face looked like
but i imagine
what my face looked like was this
this is so deeply entrenched
oh god yeah she can [ __ ] me up man
it's like it's weird it's like like even
when i saw end game i didn't cry the
first time i saw end game
it was until the second time i saw it
where i was like to get to a point of
excitement
i was just happy i was doing movies and
shows all the time three more times very
weird reactions sometimes it's okay it's
okay it's real i'm more likely to cry
if there's like uh like i know another
season's coming or something yeah
yeah because you've got that comfort
yeah and they've also been saying in the
you know interviews we don't know if
we'll do a season two at all it's only
planned for season one so yeah this is
its own
story come to a conclusion and it's hard
to say goodbye but i love that it's
called wanda
vision and both of them have strong
character arcs
that led them down a path of them being
together goodbye darling and that's like
one of his terms of edema for her is
calling her darling
tragic stuff she's like jesus christ
okay it's okay you're gonna start crying
in the middle of this conversation
it's just gonna all hit you like how
many times man i can't believe it yeah
i can't believe it but finally at least
they got to say goodbye on
actual terms with each other in an
intimate way
and also thanos just stepped in there at
the last minute
i found another reality all right
here we go one there's also hope too
because you know he enlightens
white vision with all of his memories
and all of his livelihoods and stuff
yeah and they have the whole debate
about the ship of theseus basically
to say even if you're not the original
vision parts you could come back later
and still be vision
yeah you know that's another theory that
was debunked was slapping the
consciousness of this vision into
terminator vision vision collision
i love how hayward's asset lasted like
10 minutes and
even the accident just got lured in he
was like wait wait explain this to me oh
damn i'm on the wrong track buddy let's
flip this around don't like
me please i mean the fight between white
vision
and you know our vision as we call this
vision
scarlet vision was awesome in the
beginning i'm getting some like
kind of man of steel vibes oh i brought
up a dc movie but yeah
i was getting some like man of steel
vibes at first just because there's two
powerful beings of flight fighting each
other making some destruction
right they're super menace and they have
lasers i should have realized yeah
but then i thought they really took
advantage of a lot of the choreography
and a lot of like the phasing maneuvers
too that
that the visions can do you know
honestly i gotta say though paul bettany
working with paul benny
he was electrifying me too i don't know
if it was electrifying
he did a good job on portraying two
different visions because the vision
here in the show that we've been
watching is very different than the
vision we've seen in the movies
even from the vision that we last left
off with he's a little bit more he's got
a sense of humor about himself
but he's not like as fun as he is in the
show right
watching this vision hey like before he
go
like oh no he just pissed right out he
gets
all those he gets all those memories of
wanda too i'm like a surprise
i mean i guess he has to i guess it
doesn't just come to him and he's like
whoa what the hell's going on i guess
it's a lot of processing he has to do i
i i i joked about this in the reaction
but it honestly made me think of bill
and ted 3
because i'm like he's about to go off
and like wake up and be like oh my god
i'm alive and i'm gonna have all these
emotional experiences
now i need to process all this i am
dennis caleb mccoy i don't know maybe
he's just gone off to be at peace and to
learn a little bit before he comes back
and surprises him
and i think that eased some of the blow
of saying goodbye to this vision too
yeah that wanda created because
i was like well i'm aware there's the
other vision out there and she's met him
she's yeah which by the way was like out
of the comic at first before he
goes all terminator and tries crushing
her head but at first
it is like out of the comic she goes up
to him and like pigeon is that really
you
but then you know he tries to skull
crusher that vision has the memories of
the romantic
relationship and the bond and everything
so maybe
wanda will go back to that version of
vision
or something yeah that is sort of a
dangling
point where you know they don't have to
pay that off because white vision isn't
the point but at the same time it seems
like they are setting up
a doorway for their bond to live on and
so this does leave me a little bit like
yeah i expect them both to show back up
and to meet again
although the way it's presented here
mainly yeah just makes me go where did
he go
yeah because also there's just so much
tumult happen
happening there's this huge battle and
everything and yeah with those memories
restored it's got to be overwhelming but
also he seems advanced enough to kind of
hone in on the situation
and so it is a little perplexing to me
that he just
left you know but i don't know maybe
we'll find out later well i thought it
was interesting how
she gets this point of acceptance and
then you kind of have this cliffhanger
ending which
feels like malevolent you know in a way
yeah it's funny because part of it is
like the continuing the metaphor of like
okay now she understands what her
grieving
and her conditions are so now she's just
immersing herself in them
and learning how to maneuver in them but
also it does feel very much like ooh
this is dark hold though it's like the
book of the damned yeah so it's flat out
called
so that's what i mean like through there
you hear the kids
she's doing the astral projection dr
strange thing of a jig right yeah so she
can chill on the porch while she learns
stuff and so yeah
she's studying it so like in her
meditative process still learning all
about magic
which is obviously setting up for what's
gonna happen in multiverse of madness
but you hear the kids
so i don't know exactly what's going on
with them uh like could it be
maybe there's no giving birth through
mephisto again
still let's bring that back up it could
still be and that could be an easy way
to bring them into reality
that's not just in a hex the thing is i
couldn't tell if it was coming from the
book or from elsewhere but
the book is dealing in the realms
that mephisto would occupy and that
could easily imprison in a torturous way
some
kids so i wouldn't be surprised if it's
an easter egg that will eventually
blossom into that agatha is saying
agatha knows the dark hold and she's
saying that the scarlet witch at least
is going strictly what's set up here
saying
it's your destiny to destroy the world
how there's an entire chapter
devoted to her in the dark hold and
that's all she's reading
yeah i gotta read about myself i gotta
google me i am awful
wow am i gonna do all this oh because
yeah they talk about you don't know what
you've unleashed you know they say like
scarlet witch is not
born she is forged i'm trying to get a
better sense of what
the mcu is doing with handling scarlet
witch like what is the exact take here
that we're going with is it something
wanda can just morph into like that's
just her height and sense super power
super hero identity of sorts right
or is scarlet witch like a separate
entity that's within her that is
controlling the situation now
is it the dark phoenix yeah like is it
something kind of like that
or yeah or a ghost writer like something
yeah where you tap into it but you don't
always have it at your disposal so maybe
sometimes she has more basic magic and
then in
sequence or in moments of intense
anguish or just intense
uh exertion maybe it comes out yeah or
is it kind of like a naruto
if you guys watching rudolph how he has
like the nine tails within him so he can
draw from the power of the nine tails
but
it can get to a point where the nine
tails if he doesn't take proper
control and discipline over it the nine
tails can take over him
i just want to throw out there that i
really love him
we're liking jojo like you can't use
stands
how do we get some
[Music]
it just seems like scarlet witch is
destined for some terrible things coming
her way
obviously with the multiverse of madness
set up where wando could is
rumored to be the villain of it but the
way this is going and talking about who
the scarlet witch is from
agatha's point of view and just with
that very ominous
ending with her and kind of just the
mannerism she takes on
especially when interacting with agatha
she
seems like uh she's gonna be the
harbinger of chaos
yeah cause they do an excellent job of
showing all the relatable sides of wanda
but also every
like as for as full of [ __ ] as agatha
can be at times when she says stuff like
that when she says like you're cruel
there are
moments of truth in there where you're
like yeah there's still darkness in
wanda that could turn out very poorly if
you heard learning about this power
doesn't go well it's exciting
post-credits scene she's leaving the
bruce banner life
that's what bruce does when he hulks out
and feels guilty
he lives in a cabinet everybody in the
mcu has a cabinet there's a cabin
i'm depressed now and then kind of
moving backwards a little bit here we
got to talk about something all right
here's the thing that i'm just going to
just hop into
that i've saved for 20 minutes into this
discussion
pietro uh it's
very trevor slattery i gotta say
uh yeah i
you don't like the corner joke
i mean i i didn't even i was so caught
up in the ralph thing
yeah that i cut the the boner joe kind
of flew over my head
first yeah there's a joke but but wait
yeah i was more processing like
okay so he's not quicksilver that's kind
of messed up
like not in any way shape or form yeah i
would have accepted a brainwashed
quicksilver
yeah you know i was kind of confused
agatha to control the ralph
had like a headshot of him she
did she auditioned this guy she gave him
power did she give him powers
that's like because he had super speed
and it seemed like
i really feel like they're messing with
us because when you're looking at the
the man cave he has i'm like oh kind of
like when you see him in a x-men
uh yeah next movie called excellent for
uh today's future pass
oh he's gonna make some days a future
fast you're like oh it's kind of like
his man cave
it's gotta be him it's another like kind
of trevor slattery move to me
of just you you turn it into a a joke
bit not even the reveal of ralph is that
big of a deal
yeah yeah well yeah and i mean i wonder
again
the thing about this particular show is
that every one of these still seems like
it could have a shred of truth and
casting evan peter just seems like such
a bold thing
to do that directly acknowledges
something even if the text of the show
isn't doing that
it does leave me a little bit kind of
befuddled i don't know what to
make of it i feel like it was stunt
casting intentionally to cast an
illusion over to us
the audience for a show that is about
illusions true
i guess i would probably agree with you
although
i i could still see this in some way
being like no mutants are right around
the corner though i feel like they just
want to do their own thing
fresh slate with mutants and x-men and
all that they're not going to pull
anyone from the fox universe
i don't know i i kind of think it's
messed up if there's one thing that
upsets me about this finale
it is that reveal it's the paul bettany
one is funny to me this one is a little
bit
uh yeah this is suspect this one uh
frustrates me
i i think it's frustrating because i
mean think about it at the outset
yeah when he shows up in episode five
it's very it's very exciting and you're
like what does this mean
what are the possibilities oh my god
they're doing it they're bringing in the
mutants they brought over one of the
best parts
of a universe that was dying so
yes this is great oh my god and most of
us kind of prefer
evan peters not everyone but most people
i think tend to option for uh evan
peters quicksilver
so it was like badass and exciting and
then
it's a trevor slattery joke again trevor
if you guys are forgetting trevor
slattery that is the iron man 3
not really the mandarin reveal no this
was all part of the plan because then
you know several phases down the line
they're bringing back the actual
mandarins so maybe they'll bring back
quicksilver several phases down the line
yeah and i feel like they didn't put
much emphasis on that
in this episode for that purpose i
felt like they knew people would be
upset
that also the whole thing almost felt
just like a little fun bit that they did
having him you know
delay monica for a moment it almost felt
like he was just literally a plot device
to get her delayed for a moment
yeah it didn't amount to much yeah it
creates this downward slump where it
starts out so exciting and then you know
kind of peter peters out
ha ha very cool
so many levels pedro peter evan peters
you see like the the thing to question
about that though
if i were to just like let that really
affect my viewing of this episode
with evan peters that would drop a good
amount of points
from from like 100 points of 100
to like a 94 for me it's not the biggest
deal
but the thing though is is that only
affects me because
i'm familiar with evan peters in a
completely
separate franchise that is not tied into
the mcu so let's say like i never
watched those x-men movies
and i was just going off of the story
alone yeah
would it still bother me probably not
near i think it wouldn't bother me
anywhere near as much
i'd still be like this kind of a bummer
or just something dude
just some ralph guy we've been building
up then he's not anything yeah
especially because i know that this
could have been a you know new yeah
to have a superhero again you know who's
been gone and then with agatha
not the end for her she's the nosy
neighbor role
where i think i think on one plane
and west view i guess i mean that's how
the dialogue sounded
i'm like are people still gonna people
are still gonna stay in west view the
people of west view yeah
they're gonna be like lady step out of
it get out of here
you're evil you who are you anyway you
weren't there before this happened
well and that's i mean i guess she's
just going to live with this ralph guy
because it's his house apparently so i
i that was the thing is because the hex
is gone it was one of the things that
did
uh slightly distract me wondering how
this is gonna work is agatha just gonna
live here
under this spell a million miles away
while wanda does her thing
yeah she's just imprisoned there it
seems like agatha would either be able
to break out of that or she would need
to
be close to one i thought catherine hahn
did a
really good job at balancing both the
full on witch
but not going to witch performance to
the point where you're not in a
comic book show anymore you know like
she like she did the right balance for
it and
she deserves a lot of credit for that i
still feel like
wanda could go to her and
kind of force her into a position of
you have to help me i feel like yeah
definitely and i think that was one of
the things i enjoyed them playing with
across this is for as much as agatha is
a
manipulator and is a malevolent force in
many ways there are several things she
says and gets at that are about
wanda coming to either accept what she's
feeling or learn more about the nature
of who she is and so
they have all these things laced
throughout of agatha
intentionally or not sort of throwing
out mental ideas
yeah but it seemed like she at the end
of the day she was just trying to
get to the point where she could suck
the scarlet witch out of her
but just couldn't do it but those people
of west view
was jarring like because one
really seemed like she was under the
impression she was giving these people a
good life
yeah and they were miserable and hated
her
by the time she's even walking out at
the end they're all just giving her
dirty looks and she's not even
saying anything to them like i don't
want to even look at you guys i'll talk
to monica
that's the walk of shame right there
yeah absolutely shame
shame shame some of those lines like
when we sleep we have your nightmares
i'm like damn these people have been
being tortured
yeah well the way that affects wanted
too because it even kind of
started to rip apart her perceptions in
that moment because at first she's like
i didn't know i was even doing this and
then she goes pretty quickly too no no
but
your lives are great and you're happy
here and you're feeling all the things i
wish i was feeling
well that's just uh this is what you
tell yourself when you're bargaining i
wouldn't can't process your agreement
the thing is though is these people are
now all traumatized yeah they gotta live
with this what's gonna happen
with them when they had the the episode
the last episode where they were showing
them going through west view they didn't
look happy juana takes over and
she looks like she's made their lives
worse or they could be like she's
tortured their minds but updated their
physical
circumstances will they ever get back
when we ever check in with these people
like they're gonna go back
they should make a side series where
they all go back to their normal lives
and they're like well well things in
this town are terrible but i guess i'm
myself again
damn these people are just miserable now
like damn that's awful no redemption for
the citizens of
awful betty what are you gonna do it's
not their show wanted ambition [ __ ]
[ __ ] and monica and monica gets like
some great moments in here
demonstration of powers she beats up
ralph
uh but then when she does when she takes
the
the bullets yeah when she does that
whole like phase phasing through
yeah some of the shots felt like they
were
complimenting or mirroring shots from uh
captain marvel which is very much
appropriate give me those
i can hear the cheers from everybody
else in the complex
yeah people always love those references
to captain marvel and then the big
credits scene it's funny because
hey you see hey we're getting arrested
thanks for the help of darcy great
moment
darcy's barely doing this she's on her
way to the third eleven thunder
hopefully
she got that one
like i said i don't think this this
episode is perfect
there are some things from like what's
kind of just a drop thread there aren't
isn't it we don't know who the aerospace
engineer character is
people were thinking that soldier who
showed up to deliver the item from the
aerospace engineer might have been
the scroll friend that uh monica was
friends with and captain marvel the
little girl scroll they did seem very
familiar with each other
here no no no no the one who she meets
to get the
oh yeah the her and the soldier seem
familiar with each other but this scroll
here so it's funny like
you get the reveal of okay it is a
scroll but it's random
it's not it's a different scroll because
clearly monica doesn't know who
she is yeah monica's not like what are
you because she's
met squirrels before and that line is
all talking about nick fury
obviously that's why i met my shout out
nicholas some people are gonna be like
it's nick fury guys
who's there's like what nicholas
nicholas scratch does not show up in
this game
trying to throw that out there uh no
it's it's nick fury obviously in time
for
nick cage from spider-man far from home
where's up with the scrolls she's gonna
be in captain marvel too
it sounds like she's gonna be in secret
invasion now as well which is cool i
love her character i think she does a
great job tiana davis is her name
uh hair hairs paris paris
i don't have a joke tiana harris
it's three in the morning now you know
we got there this portion of the video
is gonna be like 25 minutes but we've
been shooting for hours
we got there this is by far the slap
happiest
one division review but it's okay
she does an amazing job i'm excited
to see more of her and the prospect of
getting more of her in a couple
different places is even better
she'll be spreading her um
her cellular dna she'll be all across
the spectrum
that's the freaking part of marvel you
know some other [ __ ] happened in the
episode
you know jimmy wu used his magic
skills we got a good try taking a nap i
couldn't guys i'm sorry
it's okay oh yeah oh tommy and billy
they got to fight a little bit they got
a fight as a family
it was awesome badass looking and uh
yeah i mean they they'll live on they
have to they're young avengers they
they gotta live on i mean we gotta
torture wanda more with the possibility
of their
reality the only records of actual
goodbye is the
scarlet vision technically her vision
is back you know he's back so she could
unite with him maybe and then there's
tommy and billy who we heard at the end
of this
so so they'll live on in some way yeah
they got to be into the young avengers
regardless in the moment like there were
some
really cool seats like let's just go
over some like fun sequences of work the
whole
them fighting as a family i love that
part where she's like
you take care of them and uh
mommy's gonna go do that you know mommy
you guys handle things here mommy's
gonna go yeah
but it felt like sarah connor to me in
that moment oh yeah
yeah she's trained these kids she's like
even though they've aged quickly
they've learned a lot in the last 24
hours so
uh yeah there's there's them and
uh and that was a fun sequence darcy
getting hayward was fun
jimmy wu um was just always a blast
whenever he's on the screen
i mean there's a lot of fun stuff in
here and a lot of really good drama
and then there's some things that i i'm
like that's kind of the thread that was
dropped but all right it's the mcu
you guys live on a lot of you guys who
are like what happened to you
you'll get answered later on this show
has gone out of its way to answer
threads
you know yeah so this will answer some
like some threads that were dropped here
i'm sure we'll get made
up for later on down the road that's
that's a beautiful thing about the mcu
so much to look forward to and
the pietro thing bums me out but hey
what are you gonna do
that's the only thing that kind of let
me down a little bit but for the most
part like there are gripes and things i
could
levy i wonder how the format affects
what an episode like this is trying to
do and i think for the most part they
managed to squeeze
in everything and and get every kind of
satisfying beat in but at the same time
i'm like what what an extra 20 minutes
have done to this you know for some of
those dangling threads
as well as yeah i feel like it was
rushed or overly compact
no no no so yeah i mean i think that
yeah they stuck the landing quite well
and i think this matches
what uh matt shachman was saying which
was like yeah we wanted to appropriately
tie up a lot of things
maybe give you a few surprises and i
feel like that happened and i
am very satisfied with the theories and
easter eggs that did come true i'm not
too bummed about much else
aside from yeah the sort of downhill
thing of like i'm so excited about it
from peter's uh oh
boner you know and i think like a lot of
us have built up this this finale
so much over the theories and easter
eggs and and like we don't really do our
own dedicated videos to them this is the
most we do
uh is like these long discussions after
a reaction but we don't
like do our own because then you'll end
up in a position where you're like man
i've done a lot of videos
that's true that's why i love to like
hear but i love them though i love the
theaters and i love the easter eggs it's
part of the adventure is seeing what is
right that's not every
a lot was right yeah there's a lot that
wasn't
that didn't come true there's a lot that
was wrong but there was a lot that was
still
right even in this very episode yeah and
a lot that still
is plausibly hinted at too to keep that
magic
going and keep that anticipation going
you know all right guys well one
division finale we've come this far
what did you guys think what did you
love about it were you disappointed did
you love it did you hate it were you
like
mad did you cry did you not cry did you
crap your pants
come on if you craft your pants you
gotta tell me man
you have your pants that's the pin
coming right there
send us a picture tweet us the pants
and you'll win some kind of prize we'll
figure out later
that's true excitement all right guys
well
we have been filming for an hour and a
half i gotta cut this down
all right guys well most of you clicked
off before the
post credits
[Laughter]
check us out on patreon i'm gonna be up
all night
i'll see you guys soon thanks for being
here you rock all right bye
oh who's the lucky patron of the day
shout out today
eric horstmann i just want you to know
that family is forever
that we could never truly leave each
other
even if we tried i have your nightmares
eric
thank you for choosing me to be
your mom eric you gotta you gotta cut
back on the drinks and you gotta
confront your grief
all right it's really affecting my
ability to sleep and function all right
i know you think that i'm under a
fanciful spell and sometimes it is but
yeah i just want you to know that
you're everything that you know i'm
trying to say
look but you're mephisto you're like the
best thing in the world i love you
i will reply to you you're my ralph
boner
and you're
here i think you'll understand this
i wish you were here right now i feel
like this is
how we should hang out if we ever do
saturday to sunday sleep time
circumstances
[Music]